[Music]
hey you're bleeding
oh here oh
no no it's fine
um
we're gonna piss a lot of people off
to hell with them
[Music]
we're not even invited to this thing
aren't we nope
[Music]
uh mom's coming benjamin have you two
been smoking dope
yeah why can't you keep him under
control sons and anarchists must
give him
for generations the given and wrath card
families had
a blood feud it was never about business
your son is trespassing
it was personal mary then
give it do i need to explain to you why
this is unacceptable
end it it was an
instant scandal you take care of my
problem
i'll grant you my daughter's hand
take care of him looks like man you're
gonna dance
how do you wanna die i wanna die in a
gunfight
the choices they had made had led them
to this very
moment the fallout
it's not going to be pretty let's get
out of here
i always thought of my life like i was
living in my movie
i'm gonna be the star of your movie
this presents me with an issue keep your
friends close and your enemies close all
right dad
enough we're gonna piss a lot of people
off
do a death wish something that excites
you
dudes pretty much conform or die
honestly i'd rather die
put the fear of god in him they'll try
to stop us
i'll protect you for how long
for as long as you want me to how about
forever
[Music]
you